die Drohung Putins die bleiben in
unseren Ohren macht er ernst oder nicht
das fragen wir uns vor allem nach diesen
Satz hier
es ist kein Bluff
ist kein Bluff und dabei schauen wir in
seine Augen wo er das sagt dieses kein
Bluff glaubt man das nimmt man das ernst
oder ist es erst rechten Bluff wenn er
sagt dass es kein Bluff der Vladimir
Putin ja darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit
einem körpersprachenexperten
er ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet Michael
Ehlers Rhetorik-Trainer ich grüße Sie
herzlich ja Ela sie haben die
Ausschnitte der putinen-ankündigung vom
Mittwoch ja angeschaut was würden Sie
sagen wie ernst mein Putin seine Drogen
putin ist die eindeutig der ganz große
Bluffer dann schauen sie wenn ich mit
bestätigungsfloskeln arbeite wie sie
können mir vertrauen das ist so das ist
doch überhaupt gar keine Frage das
Benutzen Menschen die nicht in ihrer
Mitte stehen die nicht wirklich hinter
dem stehen was sie sagen auch
körpersprachlich sehen wir bei Putin
dass er wieder sehr verkrampft mit
seinen Händen mit Druck auch auf die
Arbeitsplatte arbeitet er will damit
eine Souveränität zeigen die ihr nicht
hat wenn er diese Souveränität hätte
bräuchte er diese Gestik nicht wenn Sie
genau hinschauen sehen Sie das nur ein
Daumen ab und zu etwas flackert und
etwas hoch geht das ist auch noch mal
eine zusätzliche Bestätigung er will
damit Nachdruck hinter seiner eigenen
Worte bringen
auffallend ist im Vergleich zu
bisherigen putin-analysen dass er stark
nach vorne gebeugt ist und auch seine
Schulter Schultern immer wieder
hochgehen und auch er hier dadurch
versucht zusätzlichen Nachdruck hinter
seine Worte hinter seine Worte zu
spricht von Waffen die moderner sind als
als die nato-waffe und er spricht auch
davon dass es kein Bluff
das kennen wir alle doch aus dem
Kinderzimmer wenn die Mutti ist Mutti
gesagt hat
und genau wie das meinte wenn wir es
trotzdem nicht gemacht haben ich nehme
ein putin war der eindeutig nicht in
seiner Mitte ist sondern der eindeutig
geschwächt scheint und sich viel Mühe
geben muss um souverän zu wirken also
nochmal einmal ganz konkret die
Nachfrage blöft er jetzt in diesem
Moment wenn er eben sagt dass es kein
Bluff ist
definitiv denn wenn es kein blöff wäre
hätte er diese bestätigungsflosse gar
nicht nötig das würde ja jetzt bedeuten
wenn Sie das so genau analysiert haben
wir brauchen überhaupt keine Angst haben
nein jemals Poker gespielt hat der weiß
dass ein erstes Blatt mit drei von fünf
nötigen Karten manchmal einen Spieler
dazu hinreißen lässt einen Bluff zu
geben wir wissen allerdings nicht was
als nächste Karte kommt und wir wissen
dass er die Atomwaffen hat deshalb
müssen wir das natürlich ernst nehmen
was wir daraus lernen können allerdings
ich zumindest als Analyst für mich sehe
ist die Tatsache dass er nicht in seiner
Mitte ruht das bedeutet ja dass er von
seinem direkten Umfeld offensichtlich
bereits Rückmeldungen bekommt die ihn
nicht sicherer werden lassen wenn er
dieses Gefühl hätte bräuchte er weder
die bestätigungsfloskeln noch müsste er
sich so krampfhaft und vorgebeugt am
Tisch festhalten
Dank an Michael Ehlers den
Körpersprachen Experten der einmal die
Körpersprache von valent Putin hier
wirklich komplett auseinander nimmt und
sagt der Typ der bleibt definitiv danke
Ihnen Herr elas
[Musik]